let's head back to our other breaking
news story there Sarah that's the
shooting in the UK near London Bridge
British police in London say several
people have been stabbed and injured
close to London Bridge the Metropolitan
Police says a man has been detained the
witnesses had reporters hearing gunshots
earlier some buildings have been on
lockdown and we have several people on
the grounds let's cross back to Paul
Brennan he's live for us in London Paul
what more can you tell us
well we're here on San Thomas Street
over my shoulder you can see the south
side of London Bridge you can see the
police
blue lights you can see a-courtin in
place here with police officers were
right next to guys Hospital and joining
me is a man called Connor Allen who is
an events organizer who's who was
driving a van across London Bridge
heading north on the bridge when all the
commotion happens you're starting to
shiver I hope you're okay oh yeah this
shot that just cold okay kind of tell me
what you saw yes we was we was heading
from this side of the bridge over to the
bridge to our venue steel yard just off
Cannon Street and as we were driving up
so the traffic side slowing down and
sort vans were sort of coming down the
guy you need to turn around do to turn
around
this was something that was happening at
the north side of the roof side sword
banks is that Bank so I guess fans were
coming down saying around people were
driving across the burj tell me wow we
didn't know what to do i've got event
going on
sounds like pandemonium it was Panama it
was crazy it was it was madness and
everyone then started running towards us
coming back this way so me and my
colleague Ben was staying in the band
what do we do a woman then come up and
was there's so much speculation and
there's a terrorist incidents we got out
man and as we stepped out the van police
were running up as soon as the police
passed us their side there was gunshots
oh I assume it's gunshots they were
ponch I don't really know what gun
sounds like but there was there was
gunshots quite a few of them then we
started then I knocked the van we were
running and then we stood up there for a
bit and also said our vans they're like
what's an unattended van in the middle
of the bridge I didn't know whether that
could be a problem and then and then
everyone then started running again
further down that Street I was going to
say because at one point we were quite
close to the south side of the bridge
and then we were moved back there was a
flurry of activity which I presume also
impacted you when you standing down
there oh yeah that was so it all sort of
it didn't calm down but everyone thought
didn't know what was happening and they
yeah and then they all started running
and everyone just started running again
it's sort of what you do in that
situation you run with it you go with it
and so you don't know how but how what
the extent of it isn't what it what's
going on well I mentioned to you two
years ago London Bridge attend its 2017
you know you remember them you're from
this this everyone I think everyone
remembers them and everyone has that in
the back of their head that this is that
happened again there is it is it a bomb
is it a guy running around with no life
is it just a hose you sort of don't
really know what's going on and you saw
and the scariest bit walkers is when you
talk to police officers and they're and
they don't know and then one guy that
we've was talking to is shaking and it's
a police officer everyone scared it's
your human stick to become a bit nervous
and I'm a bit stressed no matter how
much training you've got like I've
trained in events and you can't you
can't train for this often you don't
really you just want to get away from it
but and then so now we've got away from
hit and sort of thought well actually we
need to figure out what we're doing with
a man I've got an event on tonight I
think we've just so it's just spoken to
some colleagues and they're sort of very
understanding and we sort of we've got a
crying there but it's pandemonium as I
said you know we have the police
helicopters over above us not just one
with - I've seen you don't know I mean
you haven't been told by the police
anything about when I was one there was
one police officer is we've got out the
van and we asked what's going on you see
it was a terrorist it was a terrorist
incidents another police officer said
there was an altercation at the other
end of the bridge and then other police
officers just saw this guy out of the
way and I think the main thing is is
because you can hear the helicopter but
it felt like you in a bit of a war zone
like the van it's all pretty surreal and
we you hear these popping noises you
hear these you see that you hear the
helicopters you see please running
around with guns and they've got like
these balaclavas on it's more so that I
even though you don't know what's
happened you're not hurt you're not
seeing anyone that's injured it's more
so the fact that you're saying police we
have like panic laughs you know they're
not only
you know but it was all pretty like we
was there we was sitting there for about
four minutes and then it all sort of
kicked off turn around grateful for your
time thank you for joining us and don't
get don't get somewhere Walker because
you are shipwrecked as you can hear the
impression on the bridge was one of kind
of panic essentially in those early
moments people in buses in vans in cars
being told to get out as quickly as
possible what we were told by the police
that one person has been detained
we also heard reports that one person
who's been shot now is that the same
person is even treated but also several
other people have been injured police
are still working out the full
circumstances of exactly what has gone
on here obviously bring you all the
details as quickly as we can from here
at the scene obviously poor bread in
their life for us in central London
thank you very much indeed just a quick
recap there for viewers live pictures
coming from central London after what
the Met Police have described as an
incident at London Bridge they are the
only information that they have
confirmed is that they were called to a
stabbing nearest near to London Bridge
traffic remains closed in the area as
we've been hearing from eyewitnesses a
heavy police presence and quite a
significant security cordon has been put
in place the Metropolitan Police in the
last couple of minutes have confirmed
that one man has been shot by police as
a precaution they're responding to the
incident as though it is terror related
but they are calling for common sense
and restraint and certainly to restrain
from speculating so we will try to abide
by that here on al-jazeera certainly an
incident at London Bridge a very heavy
police presence but no word yet on
motive no word yet on any specifics as
to the attack but police confirming one
man has been shot by police at the
London Ambulance Service have declared a
major incident
they are responding but we still have no
confirmation on any any fatalities or
any injuries at this stage you will of
course be dipping back in a night of our
coverage in London so do stay with us
here on al-jazeera